cities across america now seeing a
growing homeless problem
from military veterans to children more
and more people are on the streets
meantime the u.s is letting
unaccompanied migrant children
cross the border and live temporarily at
texas military bases
and now the biden administration is
reportedly awarded an 86
million contract for hotel rooms to
house migrant family members
joining me now former hud secretary and
american cornerstone institute founder
dr ben carson dr carson welcome to the
show thanks for joining us today
thank you rachel it's nice to be with
you thank you
well you know we know that there's a
homeless problem i'm here in new york we
see it everywhere
if there's an ability by the u.s
government to open up our bases or pay
for hotel rooms
shouldn't they have first been offered
to american homeless families or in
particular
american veterans who are homeless
well one would certainly think that you
would think that our priorities would be
in that direction
but for some strange reason you know we
seem to be broken down into
this camp of virtue signalers who say
you know we're the most compassionate
people and we solve
everybody's issues uh and that's not
true
you know the money that's that we use on
people who are coming here
illegally is very very substantial
amount of money and it has a domino
effect
if you took that same money and you work
to improve the situation where they came
from
i think it wouldn't cost us any more
money and it would be a better situation
for them
in the meantime we have a ton we have
tens of thousands of people in this
country
who are homeless and who need our help
and the fact of the matter is you know
we we have the housing first
advocates just put them in a shelter i
think
it has to be housing first second and
third put
shelter over their head and then housing
second is you diagnose the reason
that they're there in the first place
and then housing third
you fix it you know you have all these
people with drug addictions
we need to work on that we can't
continue to let that
grow it will have a very devastating
effect on our society
and the mentally ill people many of them
are quite
functional if they had the appropriate
attention and care medications and
counseling
right so that's real compassion getting
people out of those situations
not just patting them on the head and
saying they're there you poor little
thing
and i'm so wonderful and you know it's
it really is kind of sickening to watch
it going on and i think
a lot of americans actually realize
what's going on but
you know they don't speak up uh we're
going to have to start speaking up we're
going to have to start
really talking about what makes sense uh
going to meetings talking to legislators
yeah making your voice known because
america
is up formed by the people dr carson
since we make our voices known